I got um I got something here I want to
throw up on the screen to sort of uh
talk to you guys about because it
happened a day or two ago on Twitter um
if you guys don't know who Jeremy boring
is he's the I guess the founder of Da
daily wire which is like a big uh you
know conservative platform for guys like
Matt Walsh and uh Candace Owens and
Jordan Peterson and all these guys right
so he was talking about attack on
marriage I don't know if you guys saw
this did you guys see it I've seen it a
couple of times yeah yeah let me just
read it's making the rounds yeah I think
it made the rounds because uh what's her
name Pearl you know she does her typical
uh you know flick boogers at something
and you know it gets attention because
she's a gal but it says over here uh
divorce is uh so so the red pill attack
on marriage is evil divorce is also evil
no fault divorce is particularly evil uh
divorce when children are the picture is
one of the most evil acts a person can
engage in and I agree with all that 100%
all of these acts of evil are common
because evil is common we are all given
it from time to time that does not
change uh what they are the fact that
women initiate 80% of divorce is evident
that some manifestations of evil are
more common in women something is
something society and frustratingly
Christian Society has been trying to
obscure since we turned over all of our
moral authority to women in the 20th
century this is where he's starting to
lose accuracy okay but we'll keep going
uh it is also evidence of a deep
societal sickness one that creates
enormous incentives for women to divorce
and virtually not through absolutely
none for men and I covered this in my
book in depth if you guys haven't read
the unplugged Alpha get it the red pill
rightly observes much of the sickness
and they even rightly diagnose much of
it but they then turn on the institution
itself an institution fundamental to
human flourishing male flourishing the
flourishing of children and the flourish
of society now let me just pause in this
for a minute and let me make it
absolutely freaking clear do you do you
actually believe that we got here today
because of marriage we got here today
because of our our ancestors marriage is
a new phenomenon it's only been around
for 10,000 years and the the origins of
marriage are the acquisition of in-laws
it had nothing to do with uh love family
any of those things it was it was to
form a a tribe and to sort of merge you
know under the bond or the guys of a uh
marriage keep the clubs in line too so
they're not wandering Barbarian exactly
like you know there was no marriage in
the days of gangas Khan there was no
marriage in like the days all prior to
all that and yet you know they still
managed some multiply I mean you don't
have to have [__] marriage for human
flourishing or male flourishing the the
state that it's in today like like the
actual Act of getting married is just
[__] you you would have to have an
imbalance in your brain chemically to
March into the slaughterhouse of
marriage because you just don't pay
attention to what it is it's not a good
deal it's it's a very very bad deal and
again I break down all the reasons why
my book I've covered it in podcast
before da anyway I'll keep going
marriage makes men men okay this is
where we get into the Manning up [__]
marriage makes men men actually what it
does is it makes most men [__] it
pussified saves men and is a picture of
the Salvation of men this is like almost
a quote from Jordan Peterson's uh
three-part series on marriage that they
put on The Daily wire which I also broke
down by the way in a podcast and
explained why it's dumb and doesn't make
any sense whatsoever we should fight to
make marriage marriage we must defend
men's rights in marriage well how's that
working like why are the gals not
getting together and marching on Capitol
Hill to do something to change the
[__] laws all they're doing is
they're saying words I've said this a
million times every time some chick says
oh marriage laws aren't fair to men and
I don't blame them for not getting
married and we have to change that good
get the girls together make a bunch of
[__] signs go down to Capitol Hill
and say something about it because they
don't listen to men they laugh at men
when we say things right we but we must
not abandon marriage okay buddy uh to
abandon marriage is to abandon the fight
beneath the fight the fight and way
which all other fights are premise
anti-marriage is anti-life you cannot be
conservative in anti-marriage blah blah
blah that's what I said there so blah
blah blah shame on you men be a better
beta and wife up got it anyway he
actually uh you know has something to
say over here about Manning up which I
thought was hilarious he said Manning up
and leading a family against the odds
and the tough and unfair circumstances
created by a feminized society that
hates men and male Shield leadership
does not make you a beta yes it does
Jeremy this is the dumbest thing that a
man can do is expose himself and his
wealth and his ability to parent his
kids to a situation that looks like
marriage to the state what do you a lot
of these tr get it
wrong yeah the these tradcons have this
fantasy that it's going to be like the
1950s and then I always remind people
the 50s weren't all sunshine and
rainbows if you the DNA test going back
to it I found out very quickly that my
grandpa are stepping out my uncles had
multiple kids I'm surprised I don't have
a brother out there somewhere but but
going back to the 1950s that was
actually very common so they paint this
image as MF and I covered this on
Thursday of how the world should be it's
never been that way it's never going to
be that way and then you get guys like
Steven Crowder and I get these coaching
guys all the time hey man I did
everything right like I'm a good old boy
I'm Christian I'm I'm conservative I I
did what should be done as according to
societal standards and they just
completely get [__] on and then I come
on and say okay here's how the world
actually works here's how you actually
get ahead and guys just blow me up in
the comments oh no no no you're full of
[__] like how how's your plan working
because my plan's awesome like you guys
saving men saving men from what I'd like
I'd like him to explain that he says
marriage saves men from what exactly
well well that's the whole of
Christianity you know but that's dream
of the traditional conservative and
these Christian guys that are doing the
daily wire is just man up and get
married and it's like okay maybe maybe
these guys have a slight Advantage
because they're successful they're
wealthy they have influence but they're
still plugged in betas right um like
Matt Walsh you know was a name that came
up in like one of the threads there you
know somewhere and he's got six kids
married for 10 years all that sort of
stuff but none of these guys truly
understand the nature of marriage
divorce and what and what it takes to
keep a woman obsessed with you and
attracted to you over the longterm basis
and when you put yourself in an
environment like you're in the kitchen
and like the heat is hot and you're in
the boiler you know when you're dealing
with a marriage type of situation 50% of
them fail after eight years less than
133% of people are still in a state of
love and less than 3% of people are in a
state of bliss so you're telling me that
you're going to sign up for a deal that
encourages her to break the contract to
take half like I have a friend right now
I was talking to him a couple of nights
ago and we have a mutual friend who was
part of EO in Toronto he's paying
$40,000 a month in [__] alimony in
child support none of the kids live with
her she has a house that's 6,500 foot
plus another property none of the kids
want to talk to her because she's a
psychopath and he's forced under family
law to pay her $40,000 a month and oh it
doesn't stop there by the way she's
actually petitioning the courts to get
$100,000 a month right like this is the
environment that women live in they were
married get to sorry go ahead finish
your thought they were they were married
for 20 years and one day you know she
just said I don't want to be married
anymore I want to get divorced and
wanted to untie the knot he's like what
the [__] you know like what do I do
there's nothing I can do right you know
he tried to save it you know he did the
typical beta thing like you know like
let's do marriage counseling and all
that sort of stuff but there's no
incentive for women to stay married when
Family Law and you know the court system
incentiv like if you can get $440,000 a
month not living with your husband and
he's forced to pay you that why would
you stay in a [__] marriage in the
house where Maybe you're getting I don't
know a [__] allowance for five or
6,000 is a stay stay-at-home mom to take
care of groceries and pay the bills
right you can get all the money and not
have to put up with his you know heard
either too that comedian the comedian
some that it could have been Robin
Williams who said I'm never getting
married again he says I'm just going to
meet a woman at hand and buy her a
house you well yeah yeah at least at
least this guy gets to um rest assure
that he manned up and did the right
thing and he the social and societal
benefits of that first of all two things
how do men get treated as a result of
Manning up like this is what they can
get
it his statement was trying to shame you
into something if I started shaming you
rich saying you're too wealthy your car
is too big what am I looking for you to
do well it's it's it's clearly Envy is
what it is you know giving you up
because you you have something that's
envious so essentially to these people
someone been single and not committed
they're Envy of that so they kind of
have to shame into doing what they've
done I'm just wondering that statement
from him from that guy Jeremy boring has
is has he gotten married recently how
long has he been married I want to know
all them stats I think all of those
daily wire guys have all been married
for a long period of time and you know
they're Shilling their lives but I mean
like look I mean you know I've said this
to lots of people privately take a look
around at everybody that you know that's
married or living with a woman you know
in a state that would be viewed by the
government as marriage and you tell me
what percent of them are actually
thrilled and happy in their relationship
have an abundance of enthusiastic
intimacy you know with their wife or
their girlfriend tell me tell me like
what is the secret formula because I've
I've been saying this for years now it's
like if you have a secret like the
secret sauce of success in a marriage
where you don't expose yourself to any
risk whatsoever and it's and it's a safe
protocol where you still have you know
Authority in the household and that
responsibility goes hand in hand tell me
who's got the secret us who's got the
solution to this because I'd love to
have them on a podcast right when it
comes down to it it's all this this
tradcon notion of the way women should
be it's male solipsism it's funny how um
how hypocritical a lot of guys are in
this space like oh women are solipsistic
or they're they're hypergamous guess
what when you get game you become
hypergamous as a guy too you're always
going for a better chick solipsism this
is male solipsism right here thinking
well I want a good virtuous traditional
women Argo women should respect this
don't think that way they work on
attraction triggers and if you know how
to build and maintain attraction and
that involves not giving away your power
to her to do that over the long long
term Rich you run that model um with the
LTR thing I run the mltr thing we know
that that is how that works and then you
get these guys oh I married my first
wife or we were both virgins till
marriage bro you don't even know how the
game works how are you going out there
giving people bad advice in terms of how
the game works and then guys like me can
skirt along get these girls and the guys
know none the wiser they've never seen
it before blow their mind so that so
that's one of the key elements to a
successful marriage is she's a virgin
when you get married right like the
chances you getting divorced and her
being unhappy in a marriage go down
dramatically dramatically massively
massively so it's like you know like all
these women that are all pushing for
marriage it's like oh are you a virgin
you're not then shut the [__] up okay
yeah someone asked me earlier in my chat
hey would you ever consider a long-term
monogamous relationship live in or a
marriage and yeah you know in my
evolution in life there could be a point
where I go the tradcon route I don't see
that happening but
it could happen at some point I don't
know what I'm going to be doing in 20
years and and I always say that if I get
into a traditional institution then it
has to be under traditional premises and
with the traditional girl otherwise I
would not consider it I would have to be
Christian she would have to be Christian
and she would have to be a virgin
otherwise I'll just keep doing what I'm
doing because I get good behavior out of
them but I think it's funny you bring
that up oh oh I want to get married now
after riding the carousel or post wall
it's like well my favorite is when they
go and get right with God and they've
like repented of their 20s it's like get
out it like you like really like you
think that you can erase your entire
history and all the imprinting and all
the baggage you're carrying around come
on and they get these tradcon they get
these tradcon bettas oh let me give her
roses let me give her the ring and these
guy again these guys are oblivious to
not know that this chick's gotten plowed
out she's gotten she's done orgies in
Cancun at some of the resorts she's got
gu guys that have been in the game in as
Zu evolving game you see stuff you're
like oh my God it is it is more decrepit
and more
I ever could imagine we brought it up
before rich I think that the wedding
industry is what a $6 billion dollar
industry and if you're telling me so is
the divorce industry right yeah a$6
billion dollar industry isn't marketing
itself isn't telling people that you're
a failure if you're not doing our stuff
and buying our product and getting into
people's heads of course of course
people would want that three month
salary on a diamond ring that is insane
yeah right yeah if I were to Mar girl I
wouldn't spend that on a steti if I were
married girl that to come close I would
buy I would buy a wagle cow if I could
or guys if you are thinking of getting
married here's one that I used to ask
girls like hypothetically if we were to
get married like I'm not into child
slavery or anything like that so would
you do a blood diamond or would you be
fine paying a third getting a perfect
Flawless uh lab Lab uh diamond and it's
it's amazing how many girls even like
your Lefty girls right-wing girls it
doesn't matter they want the real
diamond mined by little African slave
children rather than the perfect
flawless diamond so it's it's really
that double yeah that double moral right
there they couldn't know the difference
this thing all just goes back to you
know guys that are have no experience
shaming other guys into their what they
think they should do it it goes like
there's no we here like Jeremy I don't
know who you are there's no we I'm not
in your tribe I don't know who you are
you don't speak for me you don't speak
for all men like I don't there's nothing
that relates the two of us other than
like the appendage we have and the
chromosomes in our DNA I I saw something
that just got released I saw this on on
X the other day and I can't remember who
exactly reported it but there's now
studies that are linking um when we talk
like the tpe and they use the word incel
in quotes but when you typically hear
women talking about you know
misogynistic and incel language what the
research is actually coming out and
showing Bas I don't know if it's by
polling or surveys but it's the more
experience that a particular guy has
with women and sort of the higher his
the more likely he is to display these
what are otherwise known as traditional
incel misogynist views on on women which
I thought was really interesting and it
it just goes to show and you know when
you have guys that are propping up women
on these pedestals and they talk about
stupid [__] you know buzzwords like
the divine feminine and goddessy and all
that kind of dumbass stuff you can
that's how you know you can spot a dude
like this is the first girl that ever
touched your dick and you decided to put
a ring on like you didn't you don't have
no you have no experience you don't know
anything about women you know one woman
and that's it and so I thought that was
a really interesting sort of finding um
because it's always the insult of you
can't possibly think this way or say
these things because you don't get women
it's like actually the reason that I do
think this way and the reason that I
know the things that I know and the
reason that I hold these views and
opinions is because I do get women so it
it's really interesting that that's now
starting to come out and manifest itself
in reality I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out